bei nur 50 millionen impfdosen bliebe ja
fast die hälfte der bevölkerung
ungeschützt und das würde unser
gesundheitssystem weiterhin extrem
belasten
und natürlich auch die wirtschaft ich
habe es gelesen dass für einen
kompletten impfschutz sowieso eine
zweite impfung notwendig sein wird und
dann diese zweite impfung dann kommen
wird wenn die ärzte noch nicht einmal
richtig durch gegangen ist steht meines
erachtens nach auch noch ganz ganz oben
in den sternen ich erwarte von einem
unternehmen wie biontech dass man da
doch mehr faktisch spricht und sagt so
viele impfdosen sind dann und dann zur
verfügung ich denke mal man sollte doch
jetzt die kurve kriegen weil ansonsten
sind wir irgendwann im jahre 2027 mit
der 32 welle und der 18 mutation dieses
virus und wir diskutieren immer noch
müssen wir uns sorgen machen stehen am
ende nicht genug impfdosen für uns alle
zur verfügung darüber sprechen wir jetzt
mit unserem politik chef jan schäfer ja
was ist denn nun eigentlich sagt ja
biotec keine sorge das geht alles gut
das wall street journal aber schreibt
nenne da gibt's schon bei der
auslieferung noch das eine oder andere
problem wird jetzt genug für alle da
sein also das ging in der tat heute ein
bisschen durcheinander heute morgen gab
es die überraschende nachricht von
borstel wie du auch gerade gesagt dass
die möglichkeit impfdosen herzustellen
sei halbiert worden also man könne nur
rund 50 55 millionen impfdosen
herstellen statt der erwarteten 100
millionen und dann ging es so ein
bisschen hin und her und weiter und
bekam gesagt nein das haben wir doch
anfangen nur wenn man mitte november
schon kommuniziert werden artikel im
wall street journal aufmerksam liest der
liest auch da heraus dass eigentlich
seit mitte november klar ist dass es
diese 50 millionen nur geben soll
deswegen die aufregung war heute so ein
bisschen einerseits überraschend
andererseits hat die märkte also die
börsen doch noch interessiert die pfizer
aktie ging fast drei prozent ins minus
die biotech-aktie ist noch fast drei
prozent - also die börsianer waren auch
ziemlich überrascht aber was heißt das
jetzt der faktor für uns für uns hier in
deutschland
wir müssen 50 millionen also weiter wir
kriegen im stoff ja ohnehin mutmaßlich
erst im nächsten jahr
anfang januar wenn alles gut geht
vielleicht auch erst im februar das wird
man dann sehen
piontek und feierten gleichzeitig auch
gesagt es wird im nächsten jahr eine
produktion von rund 1,3 milliarden dosen
geben das heißt 1,3 milliarden durch
zwei jeder braucht zwei dosen sind so
roundabout 600 millionen menschen
geimpft werden können das sollte fürs
erste reichen es gibt ja auch noch ein
paar andere hersteller die impfstoffe
herstellen und den impfstoff herstellen
von daher glaube ich ist die sorge jetzt
zum ende des jahres das ist zu wenig
impfstoff geben wird ein bisschen und
große scheitert am ende nicht am
impfstoff sondern eher eine verteilung
möglicherweise daran die frage ist ja
auch wie schnell gibt es die zulassung
beispielsweise in den usa wie schnell
gibt es die zulassung dann in europa
hier steht ja an der 29 dezember
spätestens soll es bei uns also dann
auch so weit sein und wir wissen ob der
impfstoff von biotech zugelassen wird
aber bis dahin ist noch ein bisschen
zeit und ich glaube nicht dass es dann
am 30
und 31 massenimpfungen in deutschland
kommen wird sondern das wird alles er in
den januar natürlich weiß man dann
überhaupt darüber wann und wie es dann
zu den impfungen gibt immer wieder ist
ja die rede davon erst wird die eine
gruppe geimpft dann wird die andere
gruppe geimpft ich habe jetzt für mich
schonmal verbucht ich bin wahrscheinlich
erst irgendwann 2022 liegt damit richtig
2022 weiß ich jetzt nicht genau
vielleicht ist auch das nächste jahr
schon das richtige ja aber ganz klar ist
dass wir im alter zwischen gut 23 wollte
s21 genau und so um die 40 oder ein
bisschen drüber unter 50 auf jeden fall
nicht die ersten sein werden solange wir
keine vorerkrankung haben das ganz klar
es gibt einen impfplan in großbritannien
dort beginnt ja anfang der nächsten
woche
die impfsaison kann man fast sagen und
da werden zunächst ärztliches personal
pflegepersonal und alle menschen über 80
games werden da gibt es eine zweite
phase und dann sind die menschen um also
älter als 70 und dann kommen die über 60
jährigen dran also da kann man richtig
runter ziehen in deutschland gibt es
noch keine richtigen pläne daran wird
gearbeitet in den bundesländern
da wird ja auch geschaut was ist
eigentlich dran mit mitarbeitern im
gesundheitsamt was ist mit lehrern was
ist mit feuerwehrleuten polizisten die
müssen ja auch geimpft werden
da entstehen die pläne noch es gibt
bisher noch keinen richtigen plan dafür
aber gut jan schäfer unserer politik
chef kann entwarnung geben
wird wahrscheinlich genug für alle da
sein auch wenn derzeit medien in den usa
ein bisschen was anderes berichten aber
wenn man sich genauer durch ließ dass er
gesagt kommt man zu dem schluss wir
können uns da wir dieses jahr noch kein
impfstoff kriegen so sieht es ja aus
müssen uns auch keine sorgen macht sich
weniger an rasiert wird da wir noch
keinen plan haben wie es verteilt wird
kommt der konversion noch zeit lassen
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren